we are going to destroy the night king
in his army and we'll do it together
[Music]
[Applause]
hey everybody so we learned the title of
the game of thrones finale is the dragon
in the wolf very big connotations so I
believe that it refers to a couple
specific things but it also has broader
implications for the narrative so it
always works really well when they're
talking about two specific people like
Jon and Daenerys but it also works for a
lot of the other storylines too like you
have Winterfell in the night King the
wolf in the undead dragon so there's
just gonna be a breakdown a lot of the
symbolism and meaning in this because
there have been a lot of previous
episodes where you have two big houses
like the wolf and the lion or the lion
in the rose so based on the events of
some of those other episodes in the way
they made those titles there are some
heavy implications for stuff that's
going to be happening in the finale
so if you're finding me for the first
time it is the final episode but I will
be doing videos during the off season
there'll be all kinds of book stuff and
season 8 happening next year so be sure
to subscribe to get everything
but just starting on the surface level
the dragon and the wolf title really is
just talking about Jon and Daenerys and
there's this interesting quote from way
back during season 1 when George art
Martin was still heavily involved in the
development of the TV show so when you
think of the series as a whole a Song of
Ice and Fire that's its true name people
just call it Game of Thrones because
that's what the TV show is called it has
a number of different meanings but when
you're talking about characters it
really just refers to two people and
really what it is is this giant
sprawling series with a bunch of awesome
characters but at its core it's still
just about the coming together of these
two people in breaking the wheel as
Daenerys has said on the TV show so
George are Martin back during the first
season when he was still really involved
with the development of the show was
walking around in a lot of the directors
were getting into the series and
learning about all these characters and
said you know there's all these
interesting people that are rising up in
like Ned Stark is the biggest character
of season 1 so people thought that they
were building the show around Sean Bean
until you get to the end of the season
and find out nope it's not about him
Martin was walking around while this was
happening in responding oh you know
there's all this stuff going on but it's
really about Jon and Daenerys coming
together way back during season 1 it's
just that you have to get through the
first couple of seasons to start caring
about these characters because Jon and
Daenerys aren't that big in the first
couple of seasons like Daenerys steps
out of the fire at the end of season one
and suddenly you're like holy crap but
still for the first couple of seasons
she was kind of being led around by her
entourage sir Jorah was a much bigger
character compared to her now he's kind
of gotten pushed to the side a little
bit and she's a much bigger deal so you
see how they sort of become the center
of their own universes is they slowly
come together as they have in season
seven there was a theory really early on
that Daenerys might become one of the
big villains of the series it still fits
with the motif of A Song of Ice and Fire
there's just too many steps I think to
get to the point where she actually
turns into a real villain because the TV
show is just beating us in the face with
Cersei going off the deep end in
becoming the actual villain of season 8
because as we're talking about the
finale something changed during episode
6 about the war for the dawn this isn't
a minor thing so previously we have this
hundred thousand strong army of the Dead
we have to learn how to fight them we
need all this dragonglass we need to
band together so that we have the right
tools and just physically enough people
to fight against them but the big change
to the rules in the last episode is that
now you don't have to go around and kill
every single white you just need to kill
the one that created them so it's like
killing vampires you killed the head
vampire the other vampires that it
created go away too so that's sort of
another conversation about killing the
night king and ending the war for the
dawn because now you just need somebody
to gank the night king who is somebody
that's capable of doing that just keep
your eyes peeled on Arya Stark we need
another terrible tyrion plan but because
the title of the episode is the dragon
and the wolf thematically is focusing
more on a Song of Ice and Fire the
bigger themes in these two specific
characters so anything else any other
storyline is sort of ancillary it's like
they have to wrap things up because it's
the finale even though they're focusing
mostly on these two big ideas going a
layer deeper there's another big
storyline that they need to bring to a
head - and that's the truth of Jon
Snow's parentage
so we already learned from Gilly that
Jon Snow is the legitimate son of
Rhaegar and Lyanna because they got
married and so that throws a lot of the
succession into question even though Jon
Snow doesn't want the Iron Throne but
because of the way the TV show reveals
information like it'll drop
some clues then it'll make something
really clear they have to pay off that
ghillie bomb
so obviously the dragon and the wolf in
the title probably also refers to
Rhaegar Targaryen and Lyanna Stark in
the book she was referred to as the
she-wolf of Winterfell which is sort of
a way to describe her family heritage as
well as her disposition she was fierce
and wild like a wolf you may have heard
the story about the knight of the
Laughing tree about how a mystery knight
with a tree as its crest stood up for
Howland Reed when he was being put upon
by a bunch of other knights if they pay
that off on a TV show we can talk a
little more about it but it's just
another story that adds more context
that shows her in a really badass light
so she was not somebody to be kidnapped
by Rhaegar Targaryen she might have even
been able to fight him off even though
he was a very good fighter people point
to that moment between John and Daenerys
where he says I'm not happy about the
things that I'm good at which is killing
people Barristan Selmy said the same
thing about Rhaegar he may not have been
the absolute best sword in the kingdom
but he was a proven badass so they need
to pay off the idea that they were in
love ran off in pergolas bomb he set
aside Elia Martell who couldn't give him
that third child the Song of Ice and
Fire
married Lyanna stark and then gave birth
to the prince who he thought was
promised we're all kind of sitting on
the edge of our chair just waiting to
see something that will confirm this how
cool it's gonna be so however they cap
it off we can pick it apart but
whatever's going on in the finale
remember it's all about the story itself
is about the dragon in the wolf the Song
of Ice and Fire so you have a lot of
really interesting characters but really
the story is just about two people and
two big ideas but you know on the
converse it's nice to think of the
dragon and the wolf as the stuff that's
happening at Winterfell in the coming of
the night king who is riding the dragon
I know a lot of people are still going
on and on about the idea that bran Stark
is somehow the night King I do not
believe that theory and there's actually
been this photo that's been circulating
so I wanted to address that in this
video the thing that you're looking at
here is actually a Photoshop job so the
necklace that they're wearing that's the
same the one that brans wearing is the
Photoshop job there's no original photo
with him wearing this so someone took
this necklace off the night King pick
and just photoshopped it on to brand
that's not something that actually
appears during this series so I do not
believe that bran is the night king but
what will happen is is is there's been a
lot of potholes this season that have
given rise to a lot of big theories so
I'll try to keep that in mind when I do
my finale video because I'm sure it'll
happen again there'll be some moment
that doesn't totally make sense and
there'll be some big fan theory that'll
come out of it that's just part of the
fun though theories that don't pan out
but leave all your favorite dragon in
the wolf finale theories in the comments
below even if you don't think that
they'll come true it's sort of in that
same vein I know a lot of people have
pointed to the other titles like the
lion in the Rose which was the purple
wedding during season 4 and say that
whenever they have titles like this with
two big ideas coming together one of
them ends up dying like the lion vs. the
Rose the lion Joffrey ended up dying I
don't think the metaphor totally works
like it doesn't completely hold up
because Daenerys isn't gonna die Jon
Snow isn't gonna die and like I said the
title mostly refers to them but if you
also think of it as referring to Rhaegar
and Lyanna
I guess Rhaegar did die so you could say
in a roundabout way that one of the
things in the title winds up dying but
he didn't die til the Trident which is
much later and I'm not expecting to see
any Trident stuff or Rhaegar actually
dying till the final season there is a
new round of that HBO now giveaway going
on all you have to do to enter is just
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video there'll be more mythology stuff
that I'll post before the finale so yeah
special requests just leave them in the
comments below
but click here for my finale trailer
video and you can click here to learn
more about the history of Rhaegar and
Lyanna the stuff that they actually did
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome i'll see you guys tonight